hey you know who i was thinking about
over vacation i was thinking about benji
it really started to hit me hard how
[ __ ] up it is that he went to a
trained therapist and the therapist
doesn't want to work with him what
happened with your therapist she was
deciding whether to drop you or not i'm
assuming
you got a conclusion over the last
couple of weeks i don't i had been with
her for a couple months and so i was
starting to be at that point where you
start to feel comfortable
and you're opening up at least for me it
takes me a while with when i've gone
done therapy so i started to get to that
point where i really started to feel
like i was opening up and uh
i think i was complaining about the same
things repeatedly
and
she just said you know i think you
should consider someone else but it
wasn't like really i i think you should
consider it so in other words she
couldn't interrupt this constant
blabbering about the same thing over and
over again it no no this is i'm just
telling you this is highly unusual he is
a psychologist dave you're a
psychologist for real i am i'm clinical
psychologist
okay
why would you do have you ever dropped a
patient
yes i have about four or five in my 20
years
typically we try to be really nice about
it but
honestly it's usually a personality
conflict between our clients and us like
something about them kind of grates us a
little bit i hate to say that like try
not to
we try to spare their feelings obviously
i think it's like this [ __ ] guy
annoys the piss out of people to the
point they're like you know what [ __ ]
his money i'm not taking it i i i gotta
get rid of this guy in my life he's not
giving me enough money to put up with
this you can tell when your clients are
kind of challenging you and don't even
really want to be there right and that's
just you can't do much with that that's
what i suspect is going on with benji
hey benji what's the biggest issue you
want help with do you do you have any
maybe this guy dave can talk to you
what's your big issue uh
well i'm not living the life i want to
live
um
who do you what kind of life do you what
kind of life i'm sorry i wouldn't be a
good therapist because i'd be laughing
the whole time what what kind of life do
you want to live i would want to be uh
regularly doing stand-up well why are
you not doing regularly doing stand-up
if that's what you want to do when i've
done it over the years a couple times
like people get like oh my god it's like
you know they get excited it's me like
they do recognize me from the show i see
and it's it's embarrassing and then you
start and it's embarrassing
extremely embarrassing yeah this is
jessica she's a therapist as well
is she yeah
so i am a therapist in the prison system
and benji reminds me so much of the
inmates that i work with
that present with such significant
character pathology that you just can't
work with them i also think that his
therapist is experiencing some
significant negative counter
transference which means that she
he is reminding her of somebody that she
has come across in her life before that
she has such a deep
unresolved loathing for that she just
can't sit with him anymore and it
happens to us all the [ __ ] time
jessica i think that howard has that
with me do you think that's possible
you
benji you have that with everybody
yeah she's right